v
that's you [ __ ] i thought you were
gone listen
need to find evelyn i really don't want
to talk about her
know where she is what'd i just say
drop it i won't tell you again
we meet let's meet please
you out lizzy's
hey haven't i seen you here before
got a good memory for faces
here for a good time feast your
eyes on this tell me baby do i look as
fine as i feel
right now come on now don't be such a
wet rage
judy is embarrassing herself again hey
where are you going
nothing to say because you lie judy's
friend
grind
[Music]
stop telling every joy toy you need to
come here the hell i'm supposed to do
with them all
you're so concerned about strays go take
care of your guests
suze we're not done here oh yeah we
[ __ ] are
you just don't give up do you got
nothing more to say to each other
thought i made that clear or was i just
too subtle for you
what was that all about everyone in this
city lives in their own goddamn bubble
and either you fly high or sink into
quicksand
susie seems to know what she wants she
your boss
you come all this way just to play who's
who at the mox
listen have you seen evelyn need to talk
to her
it's important why so you can make her
your scapegoat for your train wreck of a
heist
seem to know how the heist went meaning
you did talk to her
i know how you [ __ ] up got all your
doombots killed like a real pro
caught some lead myself too
boo hoo occupational hazard for you
mercs
[Music]
you do this for fun talking around in
circles
i'm trying to make this simple just tell
me where she is
why can't you i don't trust you that's
simple
sure i took a risk we all did but it was
evelyn who gave it to us in the first
place
she knew what this was from the start
fine
looks like we're all in this piss pot
together
but you're desperate writing's on your
face
excuse me i came here with a simple
question
you're the one making me desperate if i
am maybe instead of judging
you could just tell me where she is all
right
enough get lost
you care so much find clouds
look there and where's clouds
sid case on my desk cut the address just
take it and go
mega tower luxurious
what's clouds a doll house but can't say
i like your chances if you don't know
that much
read the streets evelyn's there
you know this where are you guessing he
saw it in the tarots now ghosts before i
call the girls
[Music]
hold on a doll house evelyn regular
there
or a drone
think i just woke up one day looking
like this
this is real life not no fairy tale
i'm a woman that demands sacrifice
what are you staring at got something to
say
say it
welcome
you know what happened evelyn parker why
are you asking me
you talked to judy about her already
sure but
you're the boss you might know something
more
evelyn jumped the mock ship a long time
ago
and anyone not a mox is not my damn
problem
forget evelyn admit it this is about
judy's virtues
isn't it good [ __ ] if i say so myself
baby
so
they call me mr hands if you're looking
for pacifica jobs
call me name's v and what
no pleased to meet yous
i'm truly honored to meet you you got
any biz
call me
today
way i see the only thing waiting for you
here is getting off
or getting off place your bets
if i miss this time enlighten me
brain dance chick is hiding something no
coincidence we already saw
two tiger claws they must control the
building
i think judy's lying why
little something called intuition fee
ever heard of it
oh so what you meant to say was you're
full of [ __ ] got it
so hold on you take a blow-up doll
remodel hey watch it that's cheating
that's the epidemic
um
welcome to clouds where we know what
you're looking for
would you care to jack it to the
terminal
looking for evelyn parker she work here
hmm
give me a moment
evelyn's not available at this time need
to see her
it's important the algorithm knows best
trust me it will choose a doll that will
thrill you
our dolls can change their hair and eye
color in real time to look just as you
wish
i just want to talk to her that's all
please no need for concern your doll
will talk to you about anything you wish
check in please
huh i'm sorry she finally say anything
useful
[ __ ] the menu let's ditch this waitress
and take our special order to the chef
point blank
meanin meaning you go in as a customer
keep a low profile they want to keep
their cards close
fine we'll play our own game
all right let's do this
this will be a live session so events
may take an unexpected turn
but don't quit if you feel uncomfortable
you could miss out on something truly
remarkable
if you feel unready to handle what comes
next you can interrupt the session
immediately now for your safe board
samurai and
saved now bear with me a moment
scanning your personal profile you
should see compatible dolls in just a
second
two matches interesting
is that normal or who can say what is
normal you're clearly a unique person
with
unique tastes our system can handle it
so who will it be angel or skye
i think an angel looks good i couldn't
have chosen better myself
now for the payment and you'll venture
into the clouds
there you go
and the payments come through
the entire floor is open to you if you
wish to
wind down first angel
awaits you in booth six disconnect
please is that it
we have a strict no weapons policy here
at clouds
please deposit any and all hazardous
items with me
only two willing to spread their legs
for you
sad go eat a dick johnny
clouds is one of the safest places in
all of night city
thank you we hope you enjoy your stay
not bad but it would be much better
really
i would i can't get in what's that mean
i'm here every [ __ ] week you're
not authorized to access the vip area oh
yes i am
no sir
no dog i'm taking it up with you here
now
you got any idea who i am
is
please stay calm sir we're gonna have to
escort you outside
no shortage of wizards
in a minute i need to piss first
hey is this
guess that makes you a real
so
come on
your angel
sure why not do what you do best
i know that you're dying
listen i'm looking for someone who
worked here evelyn parker
nowhere and where she is you must see
the big picture you focus too much on
details
minor ones like evelyn please don't act
like you know me
i just want some answers but are you
asking the right questions
how can you change what has already
happened
what did you mean happened know
something i don't
what happened to you what you keep
inside and never reveal
to anyone that is come now
you know
trusted someone and they [ __ ] me over
the end but you don't expect any good of
people
not anymore i don't you wish to leave
something behind
a piece of yourself that's why this all
began
you wished to be remembered
wasn't even that long ago
i was at to grab everything and then
well
it all happened feels like that person
wasn't even me
still if i gotta die
i want to go down in history [ __ ] it
even a footnote to do
and after that do you think death is a
disappearing act followed by exactly
nothing
i'll be shredded i'll disappear there'll
be
nothing you can't know that
no but i got a pretty good idea
the thought of it doesn't sadden you
not any more than rain outside my window
or
another species going extinct well i'm
saddened
saddened to think all your anxiety will
be gone
yet you will not be there to enjoy it
[Music]
so where do we go from here
this is the part where i tell you what
you must do
oh okay be my guest you've never backed
down from anything so don't stop now
not one step backwards in this city
people die on their way to the corner
store for a scott pop
but that threats never stopped you you
dive
into the middle of it all always have
samurai
what what happened
you interrupted the session
did i do something wrong were you not
satisfied
that's gotta say know what i expected i
was hoping for a thrill or two
not a grim soul-searching debate look
baby i don't decide what happens in here
your subconscious drives everything next
time
remind me to tell my subconscious to go
[ __ ] itself um
just don't tell anyone okay about this
came here to talk to angel
not an algo parading around as a doll
evelyn parker what do you know about her
wait just a sec that's not how this
works you can't ask me about the
dollhouse or anything like that
i could get in serious trouble go please
just go
you gotta help me please i'm no threat
and she could be in trouble just want to
talk to her find out if she's okay
look i barely knew her and i have no
clue where she is
nobody came looking for her nothing out
of the ordinary happened
there wasn't incident with a client
i don't know the specifics one doesn't
ask about these things around here
tom might know he and evelyn were close
go ask him
and please leave me alone
tom who's he friend of evelyn's
wasn't a free moment they weren't
together where will i find him
he's a doll here works the vip area
booth too
thanks don't ask for me again
ever
what's going on
foreign
oh
oh yeah i'm good
i see of course i'm in more capacity
yeah i have that bike i know
do
you better keep this short and sweet two
brainwashed sex zombies
yeah i'm good got some new hardware
what a cycle a washing machine has a
[Music]
motor
[Music]
got a house special i'll take it
what do you mean exactly top shelf
looking to put the edge on not take it
off
it depends what you like go with your
gut
surprise me
[Music]
hi um i think something might have
not really sure uh i don't have your
details
sorry no idea what i'm supposed to do
i need to get in touch with evelyn
parker it's important
you and me both try calling her a bunch
of times
no luck you mean to say she's not here
she had an accident needed to go to a
special clinic in osaka
or oslo i think it was oslo for a new
face plate
tell you herself she was skipping town
nah
just didn't show up for work wasn't
picking up either so
i asked woodman what was up told me she
left
like i said
nice woodman of course who is he in in
what capacity mr forrest
but everybody calls him woody i really
know
why okay mr forrest then what's his
thing
he's kind of like our caretaker finds
new talent
deals with ugly situations
got it could it be woodman
finally shed some light on this [ __ ]
show
man can only dream the skull sponges and
these
dolls ah that's what they should be
replacing
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
got some new hardware
the washing machine has a motor uh
can we
all right no clients allowed in here
bear chairman close the door on your way
out would you
or as you can see i'm very busy
looking for a girl named evelyn parker
um
what the [ __ ] going on
well aren't you the king of fuck-ups
you not help me now what
el why don't you just scan the truth
from his gray lifeless eyes
or scour his comp
[Music]
that just might work
shoulder off to a ripper ship was busted
go to center to get it patched up a
ripper named
fingers in a back alley for hookers
sounds like a joy toys wet dream
so
oh
i'm required to return your weapons even
though i'd rather not
hey i don't know anything i just work
here
killing is fun
what the [ __ ]
nice work back there ever thought of
applying for the diplomatic core
i think fingers got her i think we'll
find her there v if i could see that
far i wouldn't be a [ __ ] ghost on a
chip in a corpse's head right now
where you got to coward you think
fingers got her
i think we'll find her there v if i
could see that far i wouldn't be a
[ __ ] ghost on a chip in a corpse's
head right now
i think fingers got her i think we'll
find her there v if i could see that far
i wouldn't be a [ __ ]
ghost on a chip in a corpse's head right
now
don't have time to massage egos i
respect that
of course you do you'd have loved to
drop the h-bomb in this place
no need to go so ott i've got other
methods
one thing's for sure though claus won't
forget this
uh
you had a plan you tried it fell flat
now you're flat don't look in any
condition to find helmet